I was arrested for a murder
on a release without charge and went to
a pub in the night time walking back
with a girl
from the pub I thought was invincible my
mate was in a pub I was drunk he was
saying come out finger I'll drop you
omelette like that no nobody got me
and then
Apparently one of my soul called mates
phoned up the shooters and told them
which way I was walking and
that's when I got shot 27 times
what sort of um criminal activity we've
seen growing up a criminality the first
person I see never gets stabbed was my
dad
my mom stopped my dad in his chest his
shoulder and his arm
do you know somebody I became violent
because
what I seen are omelette Behavior so to
speak you know
went from selling weed
something crack everyone 13 years old on
the street carrying knives carrying guns
I can say this because I've got a
conviction for both
so it went from
not so much violence to a lot of
violence pretty quick
at one stage the area that I grew up in
I would have think I would have thought
it was quite good but then as I got
older into my early teens
um I started to feel the impact of the
area we started to take that things
changed it was like a Rastafarian it was
our parents a Rastafarian so there was a
lot of culture within our households
then probably
from the late 80s
that's when you started to see a lot of
breakdowns within the family so a lot of
like by the time we was five are my our
dad was gone it was just our mom and
then things started to change because
the culture was changing it was it went
from righteousness to gangster [ __ ] it's
more black on black crime no it wasn't
black against whites when I was growing
up obviously we had white Bridges and
mixed race but it was like black on
black do you know what I mean whereas
were quick to
pick up we're quick to come together and
tell a white guy when he's calling our
man a black manner
but we're willing to kill each other
easy as well do you know what I mean and
a lot of my beef is with people that I
went to school with some of them have
stayed at their house and they've stayed
at my house as a kid
I didn't really get pushed into it I
chose to do it because we bought we're
both big men and we both admit that we
had choices the first time I got
arrested I got caught in McDonald's with
Michelle the last time I was arrested I
got caught with McDonald's with 500
bullets but I wanted to be a man by
looking up to the
next generation of my brethrens I took
on the aspirations to become a gangster
I took very early by the time I was 10
11 I I took on those aspirations I sent
two bad boy films Menace to Society boys
in the hood and yo like like I say all
the time like yo them people there they
was the first people I looked at and
thought yo I want to be like him I want
to do everything that he does so I just
so for me I just started to take on that
kind of perception that kind of persona
give me another give me two years I was
I was I was involved I was around those
kind of people so we was more like on a
gang banging thing like even for myself
then it wasn't even really about money
it was about your raising money to go so
we can go and roll out raising money so
we can buy dope so we can buy guns to go
and roll out it was really this was our
religion we used to live by these rules
we used to live like this is how
everything these guys are saying within
their mute Within the Music like y'all
kill this boss that showed this or dude
like I used to literally eat sleep and
breathe them that that way of life so at
that time when I was in it it was like
I actually believe it was the right
thing to do started rolling with knives
and that when I was 14 but 16 I think
that was the first time I got shot after
when I was 16 and from there I was just
it was Guns it wasn't that there was a
it wasn't even about knives it was just
guns
were were at a certain place in our
childhood then by the term we get to 12
13 we start to take on certain
aspirations and then by the time we get
to 60
it's like we're almost in a full it's
we're in the full swing of it
yeah I'd never forget the first time I
got shot after I was like 16 as I said I
was with my little brother and
um we were standing up talking to two
girls two females late in the night and
I would say I wasn't even in beef then I
wasn't I didn't have I wasn't a an
Affiliated I was I wasn't a non-gang
member at that time
um but the area that I lived in was gang
affiliated so it was late in the night
we're chatting to girls and
I've turned around and there's two heads
and all I can see is eyes hiding in the
grass and I said yo geezers everyone
started running and there's shots was
flying afterwards
sliding through fences and the the
bullets are licking off the fences
yeah that was that was the first time
that first time had me I had nightmares
after that I see my best mate get
murdered
in a bakery we went to get almond cheese
and salted tomato ketchup two of us went
in the bakery one of us come out
I was fortunate he wasn't but we can't
let his name die in vain he didn't die
in vain so
yeah and obviously I got I I got shot in
it I got shot the first time I got shot
I was going towards
I just put down my machines and I was
going to a girl's house going to the
food shop first I was riding in the park
and I seen a man jump from behind his
tree so I jumped off the bike and let it
roll towards and turn around and he let
off about 10 shots and he caught me
underneath my foot to come out my side
of my leg I got around two corners
and then the second time I got shot
um I've just been released for that
morning I was arrested for a murder on a
release without charge and went to a pub
in the night time walking back with a
girl
from the Pope I thought was invincible
my mate was in a pump I was drunk he was
saying come our finger I'll drop you
almost like that now nobody got fought
with me
and then
Apparently one of me so-called mates
phoned up the shooters and told them
which I was walking and
that's when I got shot 27 times the girl
got shot once in her chest and once in
her hand
and I threw on the floor and I took all
the shots someone put a gun near me and
lay it off I don't know if they didn't
have the balls or if the power of the
gun just made it made it but fire kind
of the bullet just glanced off the side
of me head I got up and walked and
that's all I was worried about the of of
this cut here getting shot back then
it's just like occupational hazard it's
like we was going out to work and you
could get shot he could Escape you could
shoot someone you could end up in jail
it's it's one of them things it's just a
look at a drill whether you live or die
back then I've lost over 30 friends and
family to murder and over 70 people that
have been murdered it was all [ __ ]
nobody deserves to die over drugs no one
deserves to die for women no one
deserves to die over money no one
shouldn't be killing each in a room with
such stupid little things
in the in a sense you have to realize
that's how it's going to go if I'm a bad
man and you're a bad man and we've both
got this bad man mentality when we have
a disagreement
the first thing we're going to do is go
to some bad man business people are
dying for offer for their ego people are
literally getting killed and dying for
their ego everybody wanted to be a bad
man so
nobody weren't going to take certain
things take certain disrespects or what
even people believe to be disrespect
it's like if you ask nine out of 10
people these guys have carried on this
generation War what did it start they
don't know they don't know the person
that first instigated it but they're
willing to die for it but they're not
willing to live for the kids or the
family and so on okay and I can't see
kids doing that even big men I tell big
man you should guide their knees Rock
these kids that are doing wrong to do
righteous stuff because you know when
you go to jail and you're willing to
kill and die for these people they're
not even looking at foodie family when
you're in jail
how many times were you both in and out
of prison like what was the longest time
you had to do I I received three
sentences talking and so so in years 10
months and the longest time I was in
there five and a half years
and um these was like people say
sentences I've gone higher the oven
they've gone higher but now you only do
off when I've done sentences it was
two-fifths so
um I was obviously I was active in jail
I was I was up to no good at dealing
with narcotics and things like that
paying for people to get done in and
paying for screws to get buckets of [ __ ]
and piss thrown over them because I
didn't like them and things like that
um I was selling phones in there and
jail you know what people say Jail's
easy it might be easy when you're stood
up there on a landing with your boys
putting that false smile on but when you
go back to yourself you're a sad old
soul because you miss your mom you miss
your family but like I tell these kids
you miss them when
something's happening it's like when
you're willing to die for your boys and
you get stabbed up for your boys use it
you're crying for you're not crying for
your boys you're crying for your mum so
you need to be thinking more about your
mum when you're getting involved in
[ __ ] I'm Gonna Keep It Real you know
gel is easy when you're a bum when
you're a bum you got no prospects you
got no ambition Jail's easy gel's cool
because yo you're not doing nothing
there's no progress you're not moving
forward you're just thinking about when
to get out or when you're getting out
there's like so for me
like being okay with being in jail is is
you you're born you're thinking like a
bum you got a bombing bombing mentality
like I'll be honest I hated gel I don't
like it I've never ever liked it I hated
every minute of it in fact when I was in
jail the
my
only priority was getting the [ __ ] out
was getting out of jail I didn't care
about nothing while I was in jail I just
want to go home I'm doing everything I
can to make sure I go home at the
earliest date that's how I that's how I
experienced Joe I actually don't
remember how many times I've been to
jail exactly I have to work it out but
it's around about seven I didn't I
didn't like one long sentence I'd say
and then the rest has been
like take me off the road for a little
bit and then I get I'll get through
after release give me two weeks and I've
totally forgot what that experience was
like and a like and now I'm back into
the swing of things like like it like it
didn't happen prison is not about
Rehabilitation it I don't even think it
I don't think it rehabilitates the
average inmate in fact many inmates
statistically go to jail and come out
worse
um
I think the rehabilitation has to start
with
you as a person wanting to change
and then taking the steps to do that
and what were the worst things you were
seeing in there
people getting stabbed like it's it's
just what you see on the streets
that's what they say on the road but
maybe more
um not so much guns yeah yeah yeah but
it's the same it's the same thing the
prison is a world with inside the world
which I'm trying to say without women
then but it's the same stuff happening
the same bad stuff happening you know
it's just as bad as being on the street
who are the people you were
you were sort of withered in those jails
were there mates were they just was it
mates was it mates I don't think there
was me so a lot of them was Associates
because our mate wouldn't allow you to
go and ride
and commit crime for them or willing to
die for you it's all associations I was
in jail with a lot of dangers because I
when I went to jail I always started off
on Cutty
so I was with the murderers and
terrorists and things like that what
what a lot of youths need to understand
or a lot of people need to understand in
general anyone that's your friend is not
going to be encouraging you to put
yourself at risk in any way shape or
form so if there's somebody that's
encouraging you to do Road or do stuff
on the streets or this and that they
don't have your best interests at heart
so they can't be much of a friend
yeah mine come in 2011 summer happens
I'm not going to die for which will
happen at the same time and family and
family I thought to myself I had to come
out of this [ __ ] because doing all this
thing for friends and willing to risk my
life my freedom My Liberty
and they wasn't doing nothing for me I
had to start thinking about my myself
and my family
do you know and having your family come
and travel up and down
the country visiting is not good when
you your mum's getting strip so it's
coming on visits and things like that
um and I had 2011 I left it all behind
and I'm not looked back since the only
time I've looked back is to see how far
I come I don't look over my shoulder
where I live because I know that the big
man upstairs has got me who else gets
shot 27 times one occasion gets shot
once on two occasions and stab seven
times and it's still there to tell the
tale
you know so I know the big man's got me
I believe that's a higher power do you
know
um for me I'll be honest gel never
changed me one bit y'all never had no
impact in me um one or me changing I
think
in fact I don't think I know I became
unhappy with my life and I wanted to
start changing it
um so I literally started to research I
went on as I said I went on a journey of
learning
that journey of learning opened my mind
it gave me a greater awareness to what
was happening around the world what was
happening with myself and I started I
literally
learned through my experience how I
became the way
I was and then from that I started to
learn how I could change it how I could
be a new person how I could bring a new
smart for me was learning having having
the desire to change and then starting
to learn like if you really want to
change your life this is these are the
things that you need to do so for me it
was a journey of learning the first five
years was hell it was how I hadn't I had
everybody turn against me everyone I
grew up would turn against me from my
perspective everyone that I grew up and
turned against me if I was a weakling
I would have just folded and content and
folded and went back into the and
continued back into the lifestyle I had
to be a whole I you know I had to stay
strong within myself within my mind I
had to fight an internal battle because
at that time there was an internal
battle going on in my head like yo I
need to I need to light up something I
need to I need to do so I need to hurt
someone so so so the car I can't have
people talking [ __ ] about me I can't
have people thinking certain things
about me so there was a whole battle in
my head for years where it's like yo
I'm On A New Path now now I'm trying to
save my people real [ __ ] I'm trying to
save my people it's bigger than just
working with children and and this and
that I'm literally trying to save my
whole Community like it's a um
it's a culture that's been pushed on us
one it's something that is something
it's literally something that's been
pushed on us and we need to realize well
as as adults we have realized now but
it's now the young we need to realize
that you're more of a younger age to see
that yo
this this is not how we're supposed to
be living this is not us we've been
trained to live like this yeah crime
doesn't pay does it we don't profit off
it if I kill 10 of your people you kill
20 of my people no one's wondering why
we're both lost when you're in those
types of circles you almost have to
become that way
to a degree so I'd just rather not put
myself in those type of circles so I
don't have to act or
I don't get caught acting out a
character because it can still happen
that old me is not it hasn't gone away
it's still there I've just got control
of him I've controlled the Beast and now
and now the Beast is helping me to move
forward in progress
when you're chatting to young people
and you see that they're maybe going
down the same path
uh that you both said
what is the things that you tell them
and like what's the things that actually
cut through
I I tell them about you need to be
thinking about the parents I tell them
about my own situation what I went
through when I was in jail with what
happened to family members and all that
that made me have to think about
going back to that life you know I tell
them you go to jail someone happens to
your mom you can't go to funerals if
some your mom goes in hospital you can't
go there you know you're willing to die
for your friends it's it's deeper than
that we tell them I tell them I would
the reality of what happened in my
situation and a lot of people start
crying some of them will take some from
it some of them won't well some of them
all of them will remember what they've
been told
probably the most one of the most
impactful conversations I've had with a
young person
um and this was it wasn't in a
professional setting was when
um I was dropping a kid home after
school picked him up after school
because there was some there's troubles
going on and like I ain't gonna lie this
kid was kind of on it as well like he
was like he wasn't trying to back down
from whatever was going on he was kind
of on it and it was kind of just pissing
me off that he's not seeing what's
happening I'm speaking to him about his
parents his mum the house she's already
prepared herself to get the knock on the
door to hear that he's either gone to
jail for killing someone or he's been
murdered now I've literally said that to
the kids like this is what your mom
thinks right now don't you see what's
and that didn't that didn't do nothing I
got to a stage where I got angry and I
just flipped out and I said listen all
right so if you're really on this thing
I'll round up your bedrooms I'll go and
round up their mutes you go or get your
knives and I put yours in a park and you
all you do your thing and kill each
other because at least that way your
mums can get it over it they can get on
with their life all your parents can get
go through the patrol man go for the
Grievances and then they can what you
call it get on with their lives because
all the youths are now dead I left him
dropped him off
20 minutes half an hour later
his mom messaged me so I don't know what
you said to him but thank you I can't
like and I don't even know what
conversations he's had with his mom
after that but she said thank you I
don't know I don't know what you said to
me I thought I was a bit worried at
first because I flipped out on him but
he said
after that the next day for me
totally different tune totally different
tune because Danny I faced him with the
reality
little pie you're gonna summon the
consequences and I'm all about bad
consequences yeah
this Geezer mate was found now to the
floor nailed to the floor right now for
me now through his hands